surpri it's just Brooke hey it's tasty
coming down soon because I'm illegally
parked you got him a car yeah he's 14
hey well everybody's gonna get him a car
when he's 16 I got a for chase he's
really gonna like it you know because
their wheels I Lance this guy's with me
Brooke due back sorry you're not on the
list
Oh family doesn't need to be on the list
I know that cuz I made it it doesn't
matter if you're not on the list you
have to go and stand by with the losers
thank you so much for coming so good to
see you you're so tan did you go on
vacation oh no I I went on watch what
happens live you did yeah it was stupid
but you know it was cool god this
party's crazy the brothers gun so huge
my students would die if they knew I was
here right now I can get you a picture
with him if you want
oh um our with Esther Leigh I just met
her she's really really nice I mean it's
weird that she's here but you know it's
helpful to know people like that why is
she a director no she's a chip heiress
Oh surprised damn it hey is chase dream
still up there because I got him a
present I think he's really gonna go
around just around me can't play if I'm
in line for a party that I planned I
know I could cheer you up
check out my new shoes the dry-erase so
you can make him any kind he wore nike
adidas red right now they say happy
birthday chase as it is a happy birthday
child I ran here yeah someone named at
Kerry dreams feet started following me
which is so weird
because my feet are fine you should get
the foot filter yeah it really smooths
out your feet and toes for pigs oh
that's a good idea
I'm Jeremy by the way oh sorry that's
Jeremy do you yes are you really gay yes
this is so good thanks Bob
why go over there
I love you guys I even DVR and Rhoni no
Lance I'm a businesswoman now so I don't
have time for Real Housewives of New
York that's why I DVR okay two more oh
thank god I have to pee so bad
OOP Oh remember to send chasing down I
don't want him to forget about me
tonight or ever so long like use the
men's sea totally empty
jeez God he looks like do you think
anyone fun oh we took him out the back B
no one will ever even know he left
this is ridiculous I was downstairs for
30 minutes and he got this wasted you
know sometimes I feel like I'm the only
one that's looking out for him
what about care yeah he's great he's
just he's a little orange right now they
may like to him
no like orange inside
I think he's just going through
something he's not the only one I didn't
see my mom once tonight like where the
was she your mom is my freaking
spirit animal right now
very cool Mona wait I have to tell you
what happened this week I joined a gym
as you can see and my first morning on
the treadmill one of my students got on
next to me no yes I was too embarrassed
to let him see me run so I hid in the
locker room and watch clips of dogs
feeling guilty on my phone
the same thing just happened to me I had
to start working out because I was on
watch what happens live yeah you
mentioned that
yeah I mean like it was stupid but you
know some people said I was good on it
well I can't wait to watch it
Oh what I could pull it up right now oh
just um yeah I mean just yeah okay here
we go
and that's still loading it's still
loading I think it's taking a long time
because I'm downloading that foot filter
app I can't believe chases first time
getting drunk was in a club I just
wanted him to have a typical teenage
experience like mine
I got wasted on a thing of peach
schnapps under my bed and my mom found
the bottle and grounded me and then I
told her I wish she was dead and we
didn't talk for our month she'll never
get that don't worry you'll have plenty
of first maybe loses vCard the way you
did to the drummer from Snow Patrol ooh
Lance everybody no sir we're about to
get on the bridge I don't care oh all
right it should load better out here so
proud goddamn it Streeter
god damn it did you get chase a car yes
I got him a car and it's a great deal
too he only has to say Chevy Camaro and
his next three songs uber for Jordan
what uber for Jordan I'm Jordan this
isn't an uber sorry I don't like it when
the drivers talk to me what yeah this is
good
you're cute yeah thanks should we go
back inside
oh no was it was it weird that I made
you watch that yes okay
well we want to go back inside Carrie
dreams you're not on the list
Tryg a brother
you